ich habe abgebaut und hier bin ich
eingesammelt doch nicht wahr
ich hab's ich musste immer neue sachen
holen dann aber wieder geändert
verdrehte sich die tatsache dass hat
aber keiner gesehen weil habe ich in
meiner hand vor dem bildschirm erhalten
das aber von mir films sein kann man
auch mal ein bildschirm auch immer ja
natürlich mit meiner cd nokia 63 00 als
das farbdisplay und polyphone
klingeltöne ja da muss man sommer mit
bluetooth die handys ganzen aneinander
heran zu rücken damit der sachen
gesendet wurden ein infrarot mein lieber
herr roth hatte fast keiner ihm die weil
alle anderen hatten sony ericsson
da das war noch zeiten der neumodische
quatsch da stehe ich nichts wird wird
auch mal so ein ding wo sie die kamera
mit so einer klappe sofa wo das dann so
vor schieben musste das wollte ich nicht
daran
auf jeden fall ich wollte schon damals
unbedingt vor zehn jahren hatte ich so
gesund kurbel telefon da saßen wir alle
im zug bus und bisher kurbel und wir
saßen da und haben gekurbelt und wir
hatten das immer das problem dass uns
dann gegenseitig angestupst haben uns an
armen über streitereien ausgebrochen
weil die handys handys damals wogen
locker zwei kilo deswegen haben wir
allen bizeps bis zum mond und namen
haben die kurbel gekurbelt gekurbelt ist
legen wir können uns mittlerweile
innerhalb den 20 sekunden runter holen
weil wir einfach so kurbel weltmeister
sind na ja das liegt bei dem was andere
so schlimm
ich bin einfach so bin ich so grob
motorisch wie du so wenig ein unter
unter klatschen was am himmel gegen wand
interessante dass bei den von der
geschäftsreise abläuft was machst du
gerade
man scheint ja nichts was sich irgendwie
konnte ich da nicht halt paper starb
obwohl also mit zauberstab und jetzt
wirklich nicht nur dumm herum
ich bewege auch in seinem haus ein warum
läufst nähe das dass das machst du du du
bist einfach nur so mit dass die unfähig
dass du da einfach geredet
das habe ich auch nur zu gern schon mal
beobachten können anwender geredet haben
wir einmal drüber geguckt man sieht sie
grad bin ich voll aktiv hier ist barry
lane gmf
magath meinte das recht voll ab man
kommt mein zauberstab kaputt ist meint
eric packer und michael redding
ich würde jetzt bereite mich rechnen als
bei ihm kaputt machen kkr ist ein
terrorakt
den brauche ich und er ist teuer
richtig teuer für ihn ist so lang her
ohne spaß locker drei penaltypfiff na ja
das ist richtig weil ich wirklich grad
mal soviel ich weiß nicht wie ich darauf
komme aber wirst du zum beispiel euro
dafür bezahlen dass die zwei spieler
bekommt wenn er weg wäre damit dass ich
was bekommen du musst jetzt in euro
bezahlen so in das spiel so angehen so
per paypal oder so damit ihr dann wieder
kriegs weil er ihn wie verschwunden ist
oder so ja so was machen
ja aber ich glaub ich machen ich weiß
älter das junge das ist auch etwas
wortkarg wales dass das aber ich mache
wird es machen weil man ganz so gar
keinen bock drauf hat ist da noch nie zu
warten deswegen jetzt ja vor allem ich
hätte das auch gemacht habe ich sogar 34
euro bezahlt oder sogar meine ganzen
sachen weg von ich hatte einfach
überhaupt keine motivation mehr
irgendwie wahr zu machen
ich glaube ich geld bezahlt und einfach
gesagt bezahlt drei ursachen wieder
ich glaub ich hätte das gemacht schreibt
meine kommentare um einen terrorakt in
ist schreibt ihm ihr geld spenden würde
junger alter wenn ich die wenn ich den
test recht wenn ich den test verloren
haben mir niemand geklaut hat alter
schwede
alter steht dass wir richtig eiskalt
alter was willst du denn fordern für
eine gefängnisstrafe
wer das brot samstag das wären mehrere
wochen ohne dass das geht echt
diagonalball auf platz 1 dann sollte er
ist so krass treuer der terrorakt
wirklich wissen wie ich ich kann das ich
kann nämlich gar keine krippe und jemand
war mein keller und hartholz abgebaut
ich habe nichts gemacht ich schwöre ich
war wirklich jemand in meinem keller
und am anfang auch noch nicht bei ihnen
ich kann ihnen stand ende läuft ich
liebe das ist dann wieder selektiv
spielchen
es sei denn ist einen dinger können aber
auch aus versehen heute ist ihr
abschließen
ich glaube nicht dass wir können nie
haben wir auch eigentlich nicht wissen
die eigentlich auf deinen ausgang war
gerichtet oder ja eben die können
eigentlich können die ihnen das nicht
einfach kaputt man kann ja wohl nicht
wahr sein das weiß ich brauch den
intellekt ermittelt machen kann mich am
inventar habe habe ich echt nicht alter
die schmeckt einfach mal über die seite
suchfunktion
ja was soll ich damit suchen
du musst doch drücken und dann runden
doppelklick drauf dann siehst du auch ob
du in den kisten die monster von rallyes
recht ja du musst nach einigen kisten
gehen und dann doch haben wir leute
geschrieben ich hab das ja wenn jetzt
endlich auf einem verloren hast ja dann
bei jeder kiste es einmal eingeben
wo hast du keine krims krams kisten
doch ich habe nur leicht ein
er wird nicht angezeigt es müssen so
weit nicht leuchten ok und dann geht
einmal alle kisten durch die betten
irgendwo drin gewesen ich hab ich habe
mir einfach verloren
junge dinge cloud ist das wirklich
schlecht für mich ausgehen dass wird
schlecht ausgehen sind kurz davor die
aufnahme anzuhalten und in einem video
nachzuschauen gut es sein könnte was
alter hast du dich zu machen
ja du mir glaubst doch nicht ich hab
dich verstanden ich pause jetzt die
aufnahme ich mache weiter
o
videomanager müssen das jetzt vom amt
screenshot hier nebenbei die quellen ein
gefängnis gefängnis gefängnis ich glaube
bei laptops
der mann also man sieht auf jeden fall
wird es gleich abbringen ziemlich sicher
du musst tatsächlich dokumentieren wir
sehen das nicht was du siehst ja aber
ich sehe sich nur selbst an fels sie
auch einfach kaputt geht dann beim abbau
es natürlich richtig dumm aber wer weiß
ich möchte ich hab's einfach abgebaut
und salz gewesen
es geht nämlich gleich los ich wette das
war mal in die kommentare der ist blöd
und bemerkte nicht dass luca de testet
und betreut
nein habe ich auch damit trotz dessen
guter treu ich nach dem moment ich baue
ab und er ist runtergefallen
der ist runtergefallen ernsthaft der ist
uns an gefallen
worunter gefallen ich habe abgebaut und
her wenig eingesammelt doch nicht wahr
weiß wie teuer dies schreibt david de
gea ist ein armes schwein alter.de so
übertrieben teuer eine sekunde mitleid
für den ok das war schumi schumi junge
junge
23 diesmal runtergeflogen ich habe nicht
eingesammelt
bin ich denn da hätte es hat auch
niemanden die kommentare geschrieben
die wollen nicht alle tollen job
kommentar diener war beim friseur
das war ich nicht nur meine haare nicht
gemacht und nach dem duschen direkt
aufgenommen so dass erst scheumann
momentan suche ich mal
niemals hat überhaupt irgendwas
geschrieben davon
leute ihr seid die geilsten community
die es gibt bei den altar sein
es kann nicht wahr sein
ich schaue nach hause kommt inventar als
erste mal öffnen möchte noch mal sehen
das glaube ich nicht da ist nämlich nach
hause das können nach hause macht macht
macht macht man die tür auch da war da
los
scheiß über sein fenster zumachen wir
sind recht viele mücken eingeflogen ich
hoffe sterben jetzt so und nein ich hab
ich habe nämlich aufgesammelt keine
ahnung warum kehrt wieder interessant
okay jetzt setzt sich aber wo ich nicht
tue und ich tun denn die kiste
wer jetzt guck ich nach ich habe ihn in
die kiste getan und zwar an diese
position hier und jetzt ist nicht mehr
hier
vielleicht hast mal wieder jemand raus
genommen jetzt ist auf jeden fall ein
anderes alte mieter an der stelle stehe
jetzt kann ich wieder jahre dann raten
freunde was machst du gerade war seit
verbrennen ich bin ich zum ball der ist
wirklich weg wir können aber bei unserer
ding hier vorbeikommen
nicht geklaut oder gold verloren
ich verstehe das nicht sagt meine query
keine rohstoffe abgebaut meine meinung
zu heute keine rohstoffe ab doch bringt
dich vielleicht verliert hier einfach
kann dann einfach plötzlich so gehen
angesteckt ja ja kein alter hut machen
jetzt ich habe das einfach mal die
eisenbahnfreunde immer wenn ich das hier
komplett aus kleist verschwende ich die
ganze folge damit zu gucken um einen
terrorakt ist mir auch noch nicht
passiert nicht wichtig dass du das jetzt
mal was war sonst muss sie den neu
machen
alter schwede das einfach nicht mal
einfach mal weg machte auch cooler name
sofort töten oder so fragen wir die
natürlich schöner ich habe ein halbes
jetzt bin ich fast gestorben gerade du
hast eine quantum rüstung er trotzdem
nicht an von der quandt umrüstung
einigermaßen möchte gerade auf die nicht
an
schon witzig das halb tot ist ja voll
witzig
scheiße ja ich stelle mich jetzt auch
ein dass der firma weg ist niemand die
müssen wir auch noch mal eine schnelle
fusion den aus ganz optimistisch
also was ihn wirklich nicht so ohne
scheiß und ich weiß so wir wollen
alternativen irgendwann werdet ihr jetzt
werden fitness wird zu machen
ich würde etwas zurück wo das jemand
ganz hart obwohl du da im nächsten nicht
das anders der dir getan haben jetzt dem
nächsten nicht was er dir nicht tun will
wie heißt es doch an die stadt hier
steht mich als angebot in der bibel
steht
wieso steht bei broken sams wir stetig
an farfans ins gefängnis
es ist aber nicht wahr sein
jaja freund ich würde sagen ich mache
jetzt erstmal da komme ich immer weiter
abnehmen
ich weiß nicht ob mein internet welcher
weg ist trotzdem die zeit immer so ein
bisschen ab wenn ich dann nämlich jetzt
noch schwerer für dich jetzt die
sparkurs alle das kann nicht wahr sein
was hat die noch als in den kisten hier
mit pumpen pumpen alter hast du hast ihn
jetzt nicht wichtig den track wenn ja
wer weiß vielleicht ist das mein
vielleicht ist es aber auch der die sind
viel zu tun und sich so was zu kräften
und du bist ja es soll an das war ja ja
salawat in jemand weiß der studie
standen so
schreib doch mal brocken fünf schreibt
treffpunkt bei staaten aber indirekt zu
dummen ihre wohnung steht wurde gar
keinen sinn macht vielleicht als deko ja
der weiß wie toll dazu kräften ist
vielleicht haben die paarlauf all style
und das geld du weißt niemand haben den
geklaut ist so muss überlegen dass ich
das richtig powerland margaret thatcher
sie braucht schalter sterling engines mf
viel spaß